I’m going start this episode with a question.
And please, don’t cheat…
don’t google the answer.
What is the country with the biggest share
of female politicians inside of its parliament?
You might be thinking of Norway, Sweden or…
perhaps Great Britain, right?
If that is the case… you are thinking wrong.
The answer is actually RWANDA, one of the
poorest places in sub Saharan Africa.
I’m sure many of you already know this country.
At least, those of you who are as old as me...
In the year 1994, the Rwandan genocide appeared
on every news station around the World.
It was one of the biggest atrocities of mankind
in history.
In just 100 days, the Rwandan government brutally
killed almost one million people…
. This meant that 1 out of every 5 Rwandans
was murdered.
For decades, Rwanda was a synonym for humanitarian
catastrophe, starvation and a memory of the
darkest side of the human condition.
Nonetheless, 23 years later in the year 2017,
Rwanda is turning into something much different...
“Reflections from Rwanda: investing in one
of the World’s fastest-growing economies”
Yep, you heard that right.
Rwanda is becoming a hot topic in the financial
world.
A country that used to appear on humaniarian
aid commercials, now is starting to fill financial
newspapers.
And its president, Paul Kagame, has become
the new African rock star, being received
at prestigious places like Harvard or the
Brookings Institution.
Yes, of course, everyone agrees that his style
is kind of authoritarian.
Winning elections with over 96% of the vote
doesn’t sound quite democratic, does it?
But, despite all of that, who can judge the
man who is taking Rwanda out of poverty?
The figures speak for themselves.
Since Paul Kagame came into power, Rwandans
have tripled their income, and the percentage
of the population that lives in extreme poverty
is reducing year after year.
So now the question is…
How did Rwanda end up like this?
Or perhaps: is this too good to be true?
Is there some detail we are missing here?
Today we are going to answer these questions
but before we do, let’s take a look back
at history.
And trust me, this is a pretty intense story…
PREFABRICATED HATRED
Remember this date: April 6th 1994.
On this date, the plane the Rwandan president
was flying in was hit by an anti-aircraft
gun.
No one really knows who organized this attack.
But the Rwandan army, whose soldiers belonged
to the HUTU tribe, blamed their rival tribe:
THE TUTSIS.
Tutsis were a minority inside of Rwanda living
in an apartheid situation.
Local media referred to them as ´COCKROACHES´
and many of them had already escaped to refugee
camps in neighbouring countries.
But no one could have predicted that the mounting
prejudice would unleash such carnage.
´This is a warning message to all those cockroaches
listening to us…
Rwanda belongs to those who really defend
it.
Tutsis are not even 8% of the population.
If we exterminate them, no one will judge
us because we will win”
While messages like this were broadcasted
on the radio, the Rwandan army was passing
out clubs and machetes to civilians.
If any of those HUTU civilians showed mercy
to his or her TUTSI neighbours, he or she
would risk being executed as a collaborator…
This explains why many Rwandans clubbed their
tutsi wives to death and why even some Catholic
churches became human slaughterhouses.
In just 100 days, almost 1 million people
died by their neighbours machetes.
And now you might wonder…
Why did the HUTUS hate the TUTSIS so much?
Were they really that different?
The answer is NO.
You see, many African countries have lots
of different cultures and races living together.
South Africa, for example, has 9 official
languages.
Uganda has over 15.
Nonetheless, Rwandan territory was surprisingly
homogenous for centuries.
One single language.
One single culture.
The hutus, the tutsis, and other tribes lived
in relative harmony.
But, in the 20th century, Belgium colonized
this country.
One of the first policies made by the Belgian
Government was to force the locals to label
themselves according to the tribe they belonged
to.
This way, it would be easier for the colonizers
to identify who was who.
And during the first years, the TUTSIS where
the tribe in charge of government institutions
created by the Belgians.
But one day, those tutsis started asking for
independence.
And that’s when Belgium started supporting
the hutus with racist propaganda.
This is how, when Rwanda became a sovereign
state in 1962, Hutus and Tutsis had already
become fierce enemies.
That hatred was fabricated by the colonizers.
And many tutsis had to flee to refugee camps
in neighbouring countries.
Among them was the man you see on the screen:
PAUL KAGAME.
Remember his name because he will be the key
figure in this story.
Paul Kagame was raised on one of those aforementioned
refugee camps, this one situated in UGANDA.
It was the beginning of the 1980s.
Back then, Uganda was in the middle of a civil
war.
And Kagame, alongside other Rwandan refugees,
fought the Ugandan Government… and won.
This is how Kagame, as a military legend,
was born.
In the 90s, he would lead other attacks against
the Hutu-led Rwandan Government.
But the turning point was in 1994, 100 days
after that horrific massacre on April the
6th.
Kagame was making his entrance in Kigali,
the Rwandan capital, with 2500 soldiers.
The genocide was over and Rwanda had a new
government.
This time it was a tutsi-led government with
Kagame serving as the vice president…
But hold on just a second because the story
doesn’t just end here.
Imagine the scenario…
For one, he had to help lead a divided country,
where the genocide survivors had to live next
to the neighbours that had killed their family
and friends.
And it didn’t help that Rwanda was one of
the 10 poorest countries on Earth, with few
resources to export.
And on the top of all that, this brand new
Tutsi Government was not an example of transparency
and respect for Human Rights.
As you can imagine, many of the soldiers who
had taken over Kigali wanted revenge.
And during the next year, no one made an effort
to stop the executions and the unfair trials.
If this wasn’t enough, many ministers tried
to use their positions to fill their pockets
with the little money Rwanda had.
Corruption was on the rise.
Meanwhile, Paul Kagame had the charisma, the
popular support and, especially, the political
ambition to rise even higher.
This is why, in March 2000, the Hutu President
Pasteur Bizimungu resigned.
And without an election, well, the inevitable
happened…
KAGAME, THE ETERNAL PRESIDENT
In the year 2000, Paul Kagame became the new
Rwandan president.
And he came to power with two clear goals.
The first one was to unify the Rwandan people
after the genocide.
The second was to pull his country out of
poverty.
And what did he do to achieve this latter
goal?
Well, he traveled.
A lot.
Kagame created an advisory team that went
to countries like CHINA, THAILAND and SINGAPORE.
Can you guess what those three places have
in common?
Oh yes.
They were all countries that used to be poor
but, and back then, they were emerging nations.
Kagame arranged meetings with politicians,
economists and civil servants.
And from those meetings, he wrote down scores
of ideas in a notebook.
Then he returned with the golden formula to
build a wealthy country.
This notebook became the foundation for the
brand new Rwandan constitution and, more importantly,
Vision 2020.
Basically, Vision 2020 was a government development
plan launched by Paul Kagame with the goal
of transforming Rwanda into a middle income
country in just two decades.
A modern, peaceful country where extreme poverty
no longer existed.
But wait a minute because this is not your
typical buzzword-filled politician’s speech!
Rwanda’s Vision 2020 has 44 clear and accountable
goals.
For instance, it says that in the year 2020,
1 in every 3 Rwandans must have electricity
at home.
And both the Government and private consultancy
firms are analyzing and measuring the progress
on all of those goals.
So how about an example?
Well here you go:
One of those targets was to make Rwanda a
gender equality haven.
And now, the Rwandan Constitution requires
that, at least, 50% of all government positions
be held by women.
In fact, at the time of the making of this
video, the Rwandan parliament has the biggest
share of female MPs in the entire world.
And the wage gap between men and women is
lower than in countries as progressive as
Denmark.
Today, there is a brand new generation of
female Rwandan entrepreneurs leading the country.
And what’s more, Rwanda is investing the
little money they collect in taxes pretty
wisely.
In a country where 80% of its population used
to live off of subsistence farming, the government
has built power generators and roads that
increase agricultural productivity.
Now Rwandan farmers are exporting food to
their neighbours.
All of this explains why 23 years after the
genocide, Rwanda’s GDP is growing at an
average rate of 8% a year.
This is a similar rate to emerging economies
like China or Vietnam.
On the same streets where, in 1994, people
where clubbing each other to death, start
ups like the RWANDA MOTORCYCLE COMPANY are
being born.
The motorcycle factory was created this year,
2017, with American investment.
If you want to start a company in neighbouring
countries, you will need weeks or even months
to deal with all the paperwork.
In Rwanda, you’re done with all that in
just 2 days.
And, of course, this has attracted lots of
foreign investors, especially from China and
America.
And now you might wonder…
How did they end up here?
What’s Paul Kagame’s secret?
Well… my dear friends here at VisualPolitik,
the answer has a light side and a dark side…
TITLE: TOLERANCE AT GUNPOINT
Everyone believes it: Rwanda works.
Streets are safe and tolerance between hutus
and tutsies is imposed by law.
The Rwandan constitution itself forbids the
use of the words TUTSI and HUTU to refer to
a person.
According to the government, all citizens
are Rwandans and no one should care about
their tribe of origin.
Neither the media, nor institutions, are allowed
to say anything that could spark hatred or
open past scars.
And…
well… in fact they can’t even criticise
their government...
Both the police and the military are present
all over the country to make sure everyone
follows these laws.
Yes, it is true, Paul Kagame is a popular
president.
Indeed, has his own YouTube channel and a
twitter and facebook account he uses almost
daily.
But no one else has the freedom to express
their ideas freely.
And the same goes for the other political
parties.
We are talking about a president who’s been
in power for 17 years and who wins elections
with outcomes bigger than 95% of the vote.
As you can imagine, this is far from democratic.
In other words, the Rwandan model is based
on three pillars: ease of investing and doing
business, infrastructure development, and,
at the top, an authoritarian government that
guarantees safety and tolerance…
at the expense of other human rights.
And now is when we want to hear your opinion…
Do you think this lack of democracy is legit
if the country can step out of poverty?
Or… perhaps Rwanda would be better off if
they structured the country to a more democratic
Western model?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
And if you wanna learn about the history of
another African country, click on this video
where I talk about Angola, the world’s most
expensive country.
I’ve also recently started a new channel
Biographics…
And please, visit RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM, the
podcast that provided the voices on this video
that are not mine.
Also, don’t forget that we publish brand
new videos every Monday and Every Thursday
so don’t forget to subscribe and you will
not miss any post.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always…
I see you next time.